i i generally
i have a very foggy view of that world
but i tend to try to follow and i think
society should in some degree follow
the gradient of love increasing the
amount of love in the world
and whenever i see different policies or
algorithms or ideas that are not doing
so
obviously that that's the ones that kind
of resist
so the thing that terrifies me about
this notion is i think that uh german
fascism was driven by love
it was just a very selective love
it was a love that now you're just
manipulating i mean that's
i
it's you have to be very careful uh
you're talking to the wrong person
in this way about love so let's talk
about what love is and i think that love
is the discovery of shared purpose it's
the recognition of the sacred in the
other
and this enables non-transactional
interactions
but the
the size of the other that you include
needs to be maximized
so it's
it's basically
appreciation
like deep appreciation of
uh
the world around you fully
like um
including the people that are very
different than you people that disagree
with you completely including people
including living creatures outside of
just people
incl including ideas and it's like
appreciation of the full mess of it and
also it has to do with like empathy
which is coupled with a lack of
confidence
uncertainty about
of your own rightness it's like an open
a radical open-mindedness to the way
forward i agree with every part of what
you said and now if you scale it up what
you recognize is that life is in some
sense the service to a next level agency
to the highest level agency that you can
recognize it could be for instance life
on earth or beyond that
really you could say intelligent
complexity in the universe that you try
to maximize in a certain way but uh when
you think it's true it basically means a
certain aesthetic
and there is not one possible aesthetic
there are many possible aesthetics and
once you project an aesthetic into the
future you can see that there are some
which
uh defect from it which are in conflict
with it that are corrupt that are evil
right you and me would probably agree
that hitler was evil
because uh the aesthetic of the world
that he wanted is in conflict with the
aesthetic of the world that you and me
have in mind yeah
and
so they think that he destroyed we we
want to keep them in the world
there's a kind of
uh there's kind of ways to deal i mean
hitler is an easier case but perhaps he
wasn't so easy in the 30s right to
understand
who is hitler and who's not
no
it was no consensus that the aesthetics
that he had in mind were unacceptable
yeah i mean it's difficult
love is complicated
because
you can't just be
so open-minded that you let evil walk
into the door
but you can't be so self
self-assured
that
um you you can always identify evil
perfectly
because that's what leads to nazi
germany
having a certainty of what isn't wasn't
evil like always drawing lines of good
versus evil
there seems to be a
uh there has to be a dance between
um
like hard stances extending up against
what is wrong and at the same time
empathy and open-mindedness of
towards not knowing
what is right and wrong and like a dance
between those
i found that when i watch the miyazaki
movies that there is nobody who captures
my spirituality as well as he does
it's very interesting and just wishes
right there is something going on in his
movies that is very interesting so for
instance mononoker is discussing
not only an answer to
disney's simplistic notion of mowgli the
jungle boy was raised by wolves and as
soon as he sees people realizes that
he's one of them and
the way in which the
moral life and nature is simplified and
romanticized and turned into kitsch
right it's disgusting in the disney
movie and he answers to this you see uh
he's replaced by mononoker this wolf
girl who was raised by wolves and who is
fierce and dangerous and
who cannot be socialized because he
cannot be tamed it cannot be part of
human society and you see human society
it's something that is very very
complicated you see people extracting
resources and destroying nature but the
purpose is not to be evil
but to be able to have a life that is
free from for instance oppression and
violence
and to curb death and disease
and you basically see this conflict
which cannot be resolved in a certain
way you see this moment when nature is
turned into a garden and it loses most
of what it actually is and humans no
longer submitting to life and death and
nature and to these questions there is
no easy answer so it just turns it into
something that is being observed as a
journey that happens and that happens
with a certain degree of
inevitability and the nice thing about
all his movies is there's a certain main
character and it's the same in all
movies
it's this little girl
that is basically heidi and i suspect
that happened because he when he did
field work for working on the heidi
movies back then the heidi animations
before he did his own movies he
traveled to switzerland and
western southeastern europe and adriatic
and so on and got an idea about a
certain aesthetic and a certain way of
life that informed his future thinking
and heidi has a very interesting
relationship
to herself and to the world
there is nothing that she takes for
herself
she is in a way fearless because she is
committed to a service to a greater
whole basically she is completely
committed to serving god it is not
an institutionalized god it has nothing
to do with the roman catholic church or
uh something like this but in some sense
heidi is an embodiment of the spirit of
europea protestantism
it's this idea of a being that is
completely perfect and pure
and it's not a feminist vision because
she is um
not a girl boss or something like this
she is the justification
for the men in the audience to protect
her to build the civilization around her
that makes her possible
right so she is not uh just the
sacrifice of jesus who is innocent and
therefore nailed to the cross
she is not being sacrificed he is being
protected by everybody around her who
recognizes that she is sacred and there
are enough around her to to see that
right so this is a very interesting
perspective there is a certain notion of
innocence and this notion of innocence
is not universal it's not in all
cultures right hitler wasn't innocent
his idea of it of germany was not that
there is an innocence that is being
protected there was a predator that was
going to triumph yeah and it's also
something that is not at the core of
every village and there are many
religions which don't care about
innocence they might care about
increasing um the
status of something
right and that's a very interesting
notion that is quite unique and they're
not claiming it's the optimal one it's
just a particular kind of aesthetic
which i think makes miyazaki into the
most relevant protestant philosopher
today and you're saying in terms of
of all the of all the ways that a
society can operate perhaps the
preservation of innocence
um might be one might be one of the best
it no it's just uh my aesthetic
so your aesthetic
it's a particular way in which i feel
that i relate to the world that is
natural to my own socialization and
maybe it's not an accident that i uh
have cultural roots in europe yeah
in a particular world and yeah so
maybe it's a natural convergence point
and it's not something that you will
find in all other times in history
you